en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
emergencia que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde
nuestros hogares para llevarles toda la
información
-soy valentina torre sánchez gracias por
acompañarme vamos a iniciar este espacio
hablando del polémico chip cerebral que
presentó y lo mosca y su empresa neural
inc se trata de un dispositivo que fue
anunciado hace un año y que fue
implantado a un cerdo hace dos meses
los vips que escucha sus señales en
tiempo real del neural link que hester
tiene en su cabeza este chip se conecta
a las neuronas que hay en su hocico así
que entonces cada vez que se mueve y
toca algo con su hocico eso envía picos
neurológicos que se detectan aquí de los
bytes
el registro de la actividad cerebral se
envía por bluetooth a un computador y de
acuerdo con los responsables del
proyecto el ordenador analiza su
significado en la exhibición
moscú también expuso al robot que sería
el encargado de implantar estos
dispositivos en el cerebro humano en un
futuro
o propicios como esencialmente es abrir
un pedazo del cuero cabelludo quitar
aproximadamente un trozo de cráneo del
tamaño de una moneda y luego el robot
inserta los electrodos luego el
dispositivo reemplaza la parte del
cráneo que se extrajo y básicamente la
cerramos con super pegamento que es la
forma en que se cierran muchas heridas y
luego puedes caminar justo después
cuando más que presentó este chip que
conecta al cerebro con un computador
destacó que en un futuro serviría para
ayudar a curar enfermedades como el
alzheimer o permitiría que las personas
con parálisis controlen dispositivos
desde su cerebro aunque muchos expertos
han elogiado los avances en este
proyecto otros aseguran que lo más
importante es realizar todas las pruebas
de seguridad para verificar que el
dispositivo sea seguro para los humanos
y no genere consecuencias negativas a
largo plazo
cambiamos de tema y ahora hablamos de
kobe 19 y de las iniciativas que han
surgido en américa latina para combatir
la pandemia hoy nos centramos en brasil
porque este ha sido uno de los países
más afectados del mundo entero pues una
empresa nacional desarrolló una
tecnología que se aplica a bolsas
plásticas y de acuerdo con los
responsables es capaz de inactivar el
virus en un 99 9%
esta bolsa antiviral puede ser usada de
muchas maneras por ejemplo cuando llegas
a casa te quitas la chaqueta y los
zapatos puedes ponerlos dentro de la
bolsa y el virus quedará inactivo
cuando sales del supermercado a casa vas
con pequeñas bolsas que pueden
transmitir el cob y si las pones dentro
de la bolsa antiviral quedará inactivo
hemos recibido numerosas sugerencias de
la gente para instalarlas en vehículos
de transporte como buses ahora hemos
recibido requerimientos para probarlas
en aviones
continuamos hablando de hoy 19 pero
ahora en países bajos porque
investigadores neerlandeses están
desarrollando una mascarilla que cuenta
con sensores impresos en el interior que
permiten que los usuarios puedan
controlar sus signos vitales como la
respiración y la temperatura asimismo
tiene un sensor de humedad que indica si
está funcionando correctamente o es hora
de cambiar
you can take off putting smartphone
puedes pensar en funcionalidades
inteligentes y electrónicas como un
sensor de respiración o de medición de
temperatura para saber si el usuario
está bien o si no indicando una
vibración háptica qué significa es hora
de que te detengas y te vayas por otro
lado hay personas que compran una
máscara y la usan durante más tiempo del
previsto entonces al medir la humedad
del filtro también puede indicar que la
máscara ya no se puede usar y la idea es
reemplazar la mascarilla para que se
mantenga la efectividad más el objetivo
es desarrollar un tapabocas que pueda
monitorear todo tipo de parámetros entre
ellos la saturación de oxígeno y el
ritmo respiratorio pero que además sea
capaz de analizar los datos mediante el
aprendizaje de algoritmos
dejamos el coi 19 y nos vamos hasta
berlín la capital alemana porque allí se
llevó a cabo la exposición internacional
de radio en la que fueron presentadas
numerosas innovaciones una de ellas para
amantes de la cocina se llama smart food
ayby y consiste en una cámara equipada
con inteligencia artificial que se
instala en el horno y permite
identificar la comida que se está
cocinando así establece la temperatura y
el tiempo exactos para que los platos
queden en su punto
jones la cámara identifica los platos
que se han puesto en el horno basándose
en inteligencia artificial luego muestra
el plato en la pantalla lo único que
tiene que hacer es confirmar el plato
que identificó y empieza a cocinarse
automáticamente con el programa adecuado
y dar resultados perfectos
and prospects piso 2 así llegamos al
final de este espacio cuídense si es
posible quédense en casa recuerden que
la salud siempre es lo más importante
gracias por su compañía y continúen con
más en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]